With hurricanes and the refugee crisis
And the real possibility of nuclear war.
Sometimes we may feel like the end is close. But what are the biggest risks
Facing humanity, is there anything we can do to stop it?
Experts from around the world are studying at the Global Challenges Foundation
In Stockholm and the Center for the Study of Existential Risk
At the University of Cambridge this question annually
Using scientific research. Some risks lie
Millions of years in the future, like a gamma-ray burst
Caused by a star explosion would destroy
Ozone layer or even expansion or
The collapse of the whole universe. Represent our sun
Another danger is closer to us and it will become a red giant over time
To swallow the entire planet
But this will not happen for another 5 billion years.
What is near is an asteroid so large
Causing an estimated global catastrophe to occur
Every 120,000 years. While there are no expectations
For the direction of an asteroid to Earth soon, the existing data is incomplete
Despite global efforts
To search the sky. If that happens
It may cause global cooling such as the Ice Age.
However, smaller asteroids can also cause significant impact
On both natural and human systems.
A closer prospect is the volcano
The destruction in Pompeii caused by the eruption of Mount Vesuvius was launched around
4 cubic kilometers of sediment but may launch a massive volcano
More than 500 cubic kilometers.
What causes concern about this probabilities around the world is
An ash cloud that would obscure the sun, which would cause the world to cool
And disruption of agriculture. Another outbreak occurred known
About 25,000 years ago in New Zealand
Researchers predict that eruptions will occur every 30,000 to 50,000 years.
Scientists are currently monitoring Mount Yellowstone
In the United States as a potential outbreak site. But not
All the risks that threaten us are normal. Can be overcrowded
Can outweigh the Earth's ability to produce food
And other resources, and increases the risk of epidemics
Infectious due to high population densities, possibly through diseases created
Through bioengineering. However, the evidence indicates
Low fertility rates.
Will we witness the gradual extinction of humans?
Because of lack of births? Or will climate change overcome this concern?
A temperature rise of 3 ° C is very important
With most Florida and Bangladesh underwater.
While many coastal cities will be flooded. In addition
Massive fire seasons will therefore become longer and cause greater damage
The devastating hurricanes, heat waves and lack of food will increase
And drought. All of this can affect and increase
Violence, with the suffering of States now
Of the water and climate conditions that will ultimately affect
On deteriorating economic conditions. Then there are
Nuclear war, tensions over North Korea has brought this conflict to
Pioneer. With more than 7,000 known warheads with Russia
The United States, and nuclear weapons within the United Kingdom, France
China, India, Pakistan, Israel and North Korea.
Represent the hour of resurrection you created
Journal of Atomic Scientists Probability
A man-made global disaster. Although the hour has recently included
Climate change and some other developments
Put humanity at risk, the importance lies on nuclear war.
Since its inception in 1947, the farthest
We were from Midnight or Doomsday was in 1991
When it was midnight, it was only 17 minutes.
Today in 2017 indicates the hour
Midnight is only two and a half minutes, the second closest
What I've ever attached. So it can be a small nuclear war
To create a nuclear winter that would cause global warming
And damage to the ozone layer may create
Drought lasts for more than a decade.
The biggest threat ever is: researchers now believe
It's artificial intelligence. If growth continues
It became similar to industrial and agricultural revolutions
Experts predict the arrival of autonomous machinery to the stage of intelligence
Approaching the level of human intelligence by 2075.
Even if they do not become malicious or evil
What happens if those programmed machines are killed in
Wrong hands? Or when an artificial intelligence programmer does something good
By a destructive means?
Thank you all for watching this video! If you like the video
Sign up so you can watch our videos posted every Thursday.
We will put some videos that are similar to what you just saw there
About how the rich are ready for the end of the world and
How to survive a nuclear war. This year has come to an end. Be patient!
good bye!
Translation: team autrjim @